[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous vous êtes vous demandez
ce qui fait la cohérence de
l'organisation des flux sur un
territoire
dit comme ça ça a l'air un petit peu
abstrait je vous la corde pour autant
c'est quelque chose de fondamental en
matière d'organisation du territoire et
l'organisation des flux c'est aussi
quelque chose de fondamental et de très
structurant sur nos modes de vie sur nos
modes d'habiter sur nos modes de se
déplacer sur nos modes de consommer sur
nos modes de jeu tu es etc
et pour rendre ça un tout petit peu plus
concret je vous propose d'imaginer et
d'essayer de visualiser l'ensemble des
flux que l'on peut avoir sur un
territoire donné
alors il ya un certain nombre de flux
qui sont visibles qui sont assez
évidents on a les déplacements de
personnes par exemple qui sont un flux
ip restructurant en matière
d'organisation du territoire
mais on a aussi des flux de matières du
fluide matériaux de construction des
flux de biens de consommation des flûtes
denrées alimentaires c'est pas tout on a
aussi des flux d'énergie
on a des flux d'eau potable d'eaux
pluviales d'eaux usées on a aussi des
flux de déchets sur nos territoires
et puis on a aussi des flux
d'informations donc essayer de
visualiser l'ensemble de ces flux et
d'imaginer ce que ça donne sur un
territoire
c'est des choses qui structurent
énormément les politiques d'aménagement
et si on essaye juste en quelques
minutes d'essayer de caractériser
l'évolution de ces flux sur une époque
récente
qu'est ce qu'on peut constater c'est que
en gros dans l'histoire de l'humanité on
n'a jamais eu une accélération aussi
puissante aussi extraordinaire de
l'ensemble des flux que je l'incité sur
l'ensemble des territoires
alors c'est une conséquence évidemment
hyper importante en matière d'urbanisme
et puis ça a des conséquences aussi
fondamentale sur nos modes de vie et sur
notre quotidien
l'accélération de ces flux et
l'organisation territoriale
c'est ce qui a structuré l'ensemble des
politiques d'urbanisme
depuis la deuxième moitié du xxème
siècle avec un modèle de développement
qui était basé sur la vitesse de ces
flux et sur l'organisation d'un réseau
correspondant à chacun de ces flux je
caricature un petit peu l'histoire de
l'urbanisme des dernières décennies mais
c'est pour vous expliquer que
globalement on avait des politiques
d'aménagement
ces dernières années qui permettait une
programmation une conception urbaine
quasi sans limites
on avait une facilité énorme a imaginé
un fonctionnement avec des déplacements
efficace avec des services urbains
autour de la gestion de l'eau autour de
la gestion des déchets autour de la
gestion de notre alimentation par
exemple où nos consommations qui était
quasiment sans limite et donc ce modèle
de développement urbain
il nous a quand même permis aujourd'hui
d'acquérir un certain confort un confort
quasiment inégalée évidemment et avec
une augmentation et une accélération
très forte de de l'accès à un certain
nombre de biens de consommation de
l'accès à un certain nombre de biens
d'information d'accès un certain nombre
de contenus culturels etc c'est un
certain nombre de biens alimentaires par
exemple et de l'accès un certain nombre
d' espace avec des déplacements toujours
plus rapide et une facilité en termes
d'organisation territoriale
autrement dit en un clin d'oeil
aujourd'hui dans nos territoires
on a accès à énormément de choses on a
accès à énormément de choses et donc ça
il ya un mythe derrière derrière tout ça
qui a structuré l'ensemble des
politiques d'aménagement depuis de
nombreuses années pour autant ce mythe
il est quand même important sans
forcément le totalement le déconstruire
d'y apporter quelques nuances
et puis aussi quelques limites
on a imaginé structures et des réseaux
pour aller toujours plus vite en matière
de déplacement par exemple et pour
autant sur l'un des éléments les plus
structurants notre quotidien en matière
de déplacements qui sont les
déplacements domicile-travail
on constate toujours depuis 20 ans que
chacun de nous en moyenne passe plus de
temps à faire ce déplacement au
déplacement depuis chez moi jusqu'à mon
lieu de travail qu'on accélérerait
énormément la vitesse et l'efficacité
des réseaux de transport du réseau
routier en particulier pour autant cette
vitesse elle a surtout été utilisé pour
accès accentuer la distance entre entre
le lieu de travail est le dieu du
domicile ce qui fait que dans les faits
on va plus vite pour aller depuis chez
soi jusqu'à son lieu de travail
nous on met toujours autant de temps et
en fait plus de temps aujourd'hui
qu'hier pour aller sur son lieu de
travail
donc en fait le mythe de deux d'avoir
des progrès techniques qui nous permet
d'avoir des réseaux et des flux sur un
territoire donné qu'ils sont hyper
efficaces qui sont très rapides
il faut y apporter un petit peu quelques
nuances
il ya d'autres nuances derrière cette
organisation territoriale c'est le fait
que le progrès technique nous permet de
gérer des volumes énormes de flux que ce
soit des flux de déplacements ou des
flux d'énergie ou tous les autres hommes
dans des réseaux qui sont toujours plus
efficaces ces réseaux ils fonctionnent
bien
90% du temps et cette organisation
territoriale par contre on constate
quand même de plus en plus qu'elle n'est
pas hyper résiliente
dès qu'il ya un problème un problème non
connus ou non identifiés ou non
d'anticiper ces réseaux il arrive très
vite à saturation et donc avec des
conséquences qui souvent derrière le
rendent très très inefficace pendant un
certain temps on peut penser par exemple
aux réseaux aux réseaux d'eaux pluviales
on a depuis de nombreuses années
organiser la gestion des eaux pluviales
avec des réseaux enterrés qui nous
permette en gros
à chaque fois qu'une gouttes tombent sur
notre territoire qu'elles soient gérées
dans un tuyau qui l'amène très très vite
soit dans un milieu récepteur soit dans
une usine d'assainissement
ce réseau il fonctionne bien en temps
normal et le jour d'une pluie 50
n'alloue d'une crue exceptionnelle d'une
puissante nal par exemple ce réseau il
arrive complètement à saturation et dans
beaucoup de territoires
ce phénomène il est renforcé en plus par
le fait que cette organisation
territoriale
elle a permis un éloignement un
étalement urbain qui fait aujourd'hui
que on a une artificialisation des sols
et une imperméabilisation des sols qui
s'est accélérée est qui et qui du coup
fait aujourd'hui qu'on a un certain
nombre de réseaux qui sont déficients
alors que théoriquement ils sont hyper
efficace pour gérer un service urbain
qui est celui de gérer nos eaux
pluviales ou nos eaux usées par exemple
donc le mythe d'avoir des réseaux
connectés organisé dans lesquels on peut
mettre des volumes importants à une
vitesse très importante
il a un certain nombre de limites qui
sont déjà inhérentes même à cette
organisation
et puis on n'a d'autres limites qui sont
pas du tout neutre c'est des limites
environnementales
on est dans un monde fini ça a été dit
plusieurs fois déjà aujourd'hui est donc
cette organisation territoriale et cette
accélération permanente des flux et des
possibilités que ça permet elle a
longtemps était complètement déconnecté
du fait qu'à un moment donné ces réseaux
et cette organisation elle a un impact
environnemental énorme alors est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'il est tenable
est ce que ce développement urbain il
est soutenable il ya aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de modèles un certain
nombre d'écoles en matière d'urbanisme
qui tendent à imaginer autre chose
on a aussi et je fais un petit parallèle
rapidement sur ce sur cette organisation
territoriale
on a aussi et on est obligé de le
constater sur l'ensemble des territoires
une forte inégalité une forte inégalité
sur ce développement urbain c'est à dire
que le confort et l'organisation
efficace qu'on peut avoir
vers ce type d'organisation des flux on
va retrouver sur un certain nombre de
territoires et beaucoup de territoires
vont en être exclus vous voyez
aujourd'hui
depuis quelques jours et de quelques
semaines l'actualité c'est au tour de la
question de l'accès aux réseaux
télécommunications et on a un certain
nombre de territoires en france qui sont
totalement déconnectés de quelque chose
qui profitent par contre à un certain
nombre d'autres territoires en matière
de vitesse d'accès internet par exemple
et on a une autre inégalité qui elle
peut se retrouver sur un territoire qui
pour autant et connectés et et qui
bénéficient on va dire que cette
organisation territoriale efficace en
théorie c'est une inégalité entre les
habitants aujourd'hui une personne qui
n'accèdent pas aux réseaux de transport
et qui n'a pas accès à la même mobilité
car notre habitants sur un territoire
pour des raisons qui peuvent être
économiques ou autres
aujourd'hui ça a été identifié comme un
des principaux facteurs d'exclusion
d'exclusion par rapport à la recherche
de travail par exemple où un certain
nombre d'autres d'autres types d'accès
au logement etc
donc aujourd'hui ce modèle là il est
quand même largement réinterroger on a
un mouvement autour vous avez
certainement entendu parler des
écoquartiers des quartiers durables dont
il ya toute une sémantique derrière qui
renvoie à l'idée d'avoir un
développement urbain plus soutenable il
ya un certain nombre de collectivités
qui vont encore plus loin et qui
développe carrément des des concepts de
six tasses l'eau par exemple il ya des
réseaux s'appelle citation qui
permettent de réinterroger quand même
notre rapport au temps et le fait que
cette accélération permanente de
l'organisation des flux en particulier
des flux de déplacement est-ce que les
souhaitable en termes de cadre de vie et
de mode de vie
pour nous être humain avec une capacité
limitée aussi de pouvoir gérer la
vitesse et puis un certain nombre
d'autres réseaux vide en transition et
c'est qui la permettent de pointer le
doigt quand même sur le caractère
soutenable et nabeul de ce type
d'organisation territoriale
donc on a aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de d'école en matière de conception
urbaine ou de programmation urbaine même
de planification urbaine à l'échelle
grand territoire qui plutôt que de
continuer à imaginer un réseau toujours
plus grand toujours plus étalé qui
rentre en concurrence avec un autre
réseau dont on n'a pas parlé jusqu'à
maintenant quel réseau écologique par
exemple avec en termes d'aménagement du
territoire
une trame verte et bleue qui rentre en
concurrence avec les infrastructures
qu'on construit pour les réseaux qui
permettent d'assouvir à nos besoins
et puis qui rentre en concurrence aussi
avec l'étalement urbain l'éparpillement
urbain on a un certain nombre d'écoles
qui préconise une réduction
plutôt que d'augmenter la vitesse entre
un point a et b de réduire la distance
entre un point a et b et voir de limiter
un certain nombre de flux à un point a
et donc c'est plus des flux c'est
uniquement des stocks voilà derrière
tout ça il ya un certain nombre de
paradigme
autour d'eux je vous invite si vous
voulez approfondir un peu le sujet le
métabolisme urbain à l'économie
circulaire l'économie de fonctionnalité
appliquée aux territoires
mais derrière tout ça il ya un principe
assez simple c'est comment à l'échelle
d'un quartier on est capable d'être plus
autonomes alors prends quelques exemples
de deux flux classique le flux d'énergie
par exemple qui est aujourd'hui beaucoup
traité dans tout ce qu'on appelle
smartcity l'intelligence des réseaux
l'intelligence de la ville on est
capable aujourd'hui de créer des
quartiers qui réduisent d'abord leurs
besoins avant d'imaginer de créer des
flux ont réduit ces flux et ensuite de
pouvoir produire localement pour
répondre à ses besoins
donc avec des quartiers qui sont
quasiment autonome d'un point de vue
énergétique on a réduit complètement les
besoins de chaleur et les besoins
d'électricité deux principaux besoins en
termes de d'énergie et puis on a produit
localement
quelque chose qui permet finalement
d'éviter un réseau immense parfois pas
toujours si efficace que ça et avec une
résilience qui est beaucoup plus forte
la question des déchets par exemple
c'est un autre exemple assez assez
parlant on a aujourd'hui un volume de
déchets on le met dans notre poubelle
que peu importe le veau
en un clin d'oeil il est collectée et
puis traitées à l'extérieur très souvent
des agglomérations
pour autant dans notre poubelle on a un
tiers de déchets organiques qui pourrait
être valorisée sur place on a une partie
des déchets qui sont des encombrants qui
pourraient faire l'objet de réemploi sur
place et profiter à d'autres et on a
comme ça tout à son d'un certain nombre
de flux à l'intérieur du flux des chiens
on a plusieurs flux qui pourraient
eux-mêmes être traités de façon très
locale est très et donc du coup très
autonome à l'échelle d'un quartier on
pourrait prendre la même chose sur les
questions de l'agriculture par exemple
la même chose sur les questions de
gestion de l'eau de déplacement avec sur
les déplacements par exemple aujourd'hui
beaucoup de collectivités qui
s'interroge sur plutôt que de créer de
répondre à des besoins des en termes de
déplacements d'essayer de limiter ses
besoins en termes de déplacements et
donc plutôt que d'investir des millions
en termes d'infrastructures et de
réseaux pour que les flux de voitures et
toujours plus vite d'essayer de
réfléchir à promouvoir des formes de
télétravail ou de coworking avec des
espaces différents au sein du quartier
donc vous voyez que quand on dit tout ça
ça implique en termes de conception et
programmation européenne quand on
travaille sur un éco quartier par
exemple de réfléchir à des équipements
qui apporte un service urbain différents
plutôt que d'envoyer tous dans des tubes
et que ce soit traitée souvent à
l'extérieur et est assez éloigné de
l'endroit où le flux comme ans de
pouvoir le traiter au maximum à
l'échelle d'un quartier avec la plupart
du temps des équipements un peu hybride
du coût qui permette d'apporter des
services urbains donc des services
urbains pour pouvoir travailler
différemment des services urbains pour
pouvoir se déplacer autrement des
services urbains pour pouvoir gérer les
déchets autrement gérer l'eau
différemment gérer l'énergie
différemment et avec tout ça on peut
imaginer et donc la démonstration elle
et elle est aussi en lien avec la trame
verte et bleue dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure que l'impact environnemental
global et la préservation d'un certain
nombre de deux choses aujourd'hui qui
sont des facteurs de changement hyper
structurant sur nos territoires
la préservation de la biodiversité la
raréfaction de ressources le changement
climatique
on imagine qu'avec ce type
d'aménagement et de programmation
urbaine
on est beaucoup plus résilient on limite
beaucoup plus l'impact environnemental
on a un levier hyper puissant en terme
d'organisation territoriale
par contre c'est une rupture totale par
rapport aux politiques d'aménagement qui
ont pu être mené soit les chefs de
grands territoires soit sur un quartier
soi même sur un bâtiment ou un lot à
bâtir et sari interroge de façon assez
profonde
nos modes de vie
donc voilà je vous invite à suivre ce
qui va certainement évoluer très
rapidement dans les années qui viennent
en matière de programmation urbaine et
et qui va certainement répondre de fait
un certain nombre de facteurs de
changement qui nous tombe dessus et sur
lesquels de toute façon l'urbanisme va
devoir répondre en matière d'aménagement
des espaces publics d'aménagement des
espaces privés et de programmation de
services / non merci
[Applaudissements]